in keeping with the theme of you know
being a classically trained actor and
sometimes getting in your own way i was
listening to the mark maron podcast wtf
podcast and they had ileana douglas on
there and she ileana douglas worked in
my company worked with my company in new
york way way long ago oh well she was
she was wonderful on the show and i've
listened to it several times and so mark
maron threw out this line about this
sort of acting teacher ego
about how sometimes they squash people
and maybe not to be
malicious but because it wasn't done a
certain way and so iliana referred to
something where
she had done a scene and the teacher
said i'm sorry you walk through your
invisible wall you can sit down now and
so
okay i thought she might have said
something about me but good she did no
no but uh so so in keeping with that
sort of being trained too rigorously do
you think it's almost like you know just
how sort of a lawyer or a doctor they
know that there's there's certain
structures certain things that you
cannot vary from sort of left brain um
[Music]
jobs where you can't really vary from
those things whereas with acting do you
think sometimes actors put themselves
too tightly in a box
well
i guess the point is is that
um
actors are trained in all sorts of arts
they're trained to be great
movers great walkers great poets uh they
learn how to fence they learn
shakespeare they they learn stanislavski
but there's very few places that teach
comedy so
uh what happens is is that when they are
trying to do comedy there
uh
they've been taught a lot of people have
been taught well you're either funny or
not i mean so as though it was an art
form that couldn't be taught uh and uh
and you know whether they're boxed in or
not i think what i think what happens
um
is that
they
unconsciously
are
making errors that if they were aware of
they could fix immediately for instance
um
actors are taught that everything has to
come from you know their character and
their character is the hero of their
story
uh
which in some performances makes it very
kind of very indulgent so actors uh
actors who
don't have comic training or or haven't
done a lot of improv um tend to look at
their characters and whatever their
character's negative faults are they
justify them whereas in comedy the whole
point is to tell the truth about people
i mean
to tell the truth about
who you are and what you are and um i i
like to tell you know what people often
ask me well what's the you know there's
no difference between comedy and drama
in the writing and the and the acting
and i say well
that's not true drama helps us dream
about what we could be we become the
best of who we are
when we're writing or acting drama but
comedy helps us live with who we are
comedy helps us live with who we are so
i say that
have you ever seen a production of
hamlet say and you know some people
raise their hand and i'll say in your
production of hamlet that you saw or
were in did you ever see hamlet fart
people go no and they start to laugh and
i say well what would happen if hamlet
just let out a big one you know to be or
not to
and people say that would be funny
exactly
people do fart people do pass wind it
happens in life but in drama they excise
out
the things that would make the character
look ridiculous whereas in comedy they
allow the character to be
sad to be tragic but they tell the truth
about the character so so the simple
equation is comedy tells the truth and
specifically it tells the truth about
people
so
so uh actors are kind of trained to tell
a beautiful lie
uh a a wonderful lie but
uh
but in terms of playing comedy you have
to tell the truth about yourself which
is why it seems that comic actors are
you know are less than you know they're
they're they're not that attractive or
not that bright or not that strong but
the reality is is none of us are that
bright or that attractive or that strong
i mean unless you're you know a
supermodel or unless you're a pro
athlete i mean the the reality of us as
human beings is we're flawed
and
every you know no matter how good we try
to make our flaws go away or or or
overcome our flaws um
the sad fact is is that you know we're
you know we're all doomed to the
ultimate flaw which is our death
uh
and you know the dramatic artist takes a
look at her death say you know the guy
behind the camera there david say david
dies that no that's sad
um i know it's sad uh the dramatic
artist would take a look and say
a man died how sad but the comic artist
would take a look at the same thing and
say yes a man died but look how he lived
how ridiculous
because you know most of us uh are aware
somewhere that you know that
man is the only animal that has any
working knowledge of our own demise
right
and based on that based upon the fact
that we all know somewhere back in our
minds that we're gonna die what do we do
do we all sit home weeping softly
writing haiku
no we we get up we we do what we need to
do we do what we want to do and um you
know
every you know the shirt or the blouse
or the the the
you know the the shoes you're wearing
everything you put on today you put on
because it was comfortable or it made
you feel attractive or it helped you do
your job or maybe it was simply the one
that smelled the least on the pile on
the floor but everything you do every
action you take is designed to make your
life a little bit better
will it solve our ultimate problem no
we're still gonna die
but
even though some of us may despair some
of us may
be sitting home weeping softly riding
haiku but as a race as a species
we are all gonna do the same thing
tomorrow and the day after that and the
day after that because
human beings live in hope
and comedy is the art of hope
comedy is the art of stupid
feudal
ridiculous
uh uh unattainable hope
um
so the so from that
idea
um we can draw what you know a paradigm
i always love that word it sounds it
sounds so robert mckee paradigm but it's
actually an equation
comedy is about an ordinary guy or gal
jackie gleason used to call him a moak
struggling against insurmountable odds
without many of the required skills and
tools with which to win yet never giving
up hope
ordinary guy
struggling against insurmountable odds
what could be more insurmountable than
our own demise
uh without many of the required skills
and tools with which to win
yet never giving up hope and from that
equation from that paradigm we draw
these usable practical tools
that work whether you're an actor or or
a writer or director because comedy is a
very unified art form
um you know the tool of winning comedy
gives you the permission to win
the tool of the non-hero not a comic
hero not not a ridiculous fool but
somebody who simply lacks some if not
all the required skills and tools uh
metaphorical relationship the idea that
beneath surface relationships are is a
truer essential relationship a metaphor
uh positive action the idea that every
action your character takes your
character actually thinks it's going to
work otherwise why bother why would they
do that
active emotion the reason why untrained
actors
and comics can be so successful in film
and television
and straight line wavy line the idea
that uh that the dynamic and comedy
isn't about a funny guy
doing saying all the jokes and somebody
else you know kind of just supporting
them by feeding them straight lines that
the dynamic is actually a straight line
and a wavy line a straight line like a
like somebody who has blinders on
somebody who's blind to the problem of
creating the problem and a wavy line
somebody who's struggling with the
problem but because they're a non-hero
they can't solve it
you